哈喽各位同学大家晚安
我眼前的刚好有同学问到说
怎么防守抬脚后停回踩的停顺
这个概念大概就是像这样子
我用刚刚这个交易给大家看
这个好了
我在这边有吃
那这个概念就是
我当时吃的想法
其实是因为我仗着自己
今天有利润
所以我就拿利润里面
一些子弹来玩
我的概念是这一根之后
我抓出打击局
其实我还要再多补五口在这边
只是他没有让我吃到
那我的防守
其实就只是防守边界以外
那如果你是指这种
抬脚后的概念
我看一下我今天投影片
其实我等一下要准备
让我待会用我等一下的投影片来讲
抬脚后的这个防守
有同学说他吃了那个AMD跟Tesla
然后我一看了AMD的价格
我切了小时K我一看我第一秒钟
我就说189为什么
来各位在这一根K棒的瞬间
你看到什么东西
这根K棒是不是我们所熟悉的边界
然后干嘛有没有破
破了对不对
边界跌破又收回边界内
这不就是189吗
这个位置对过来大概就是189的这个地方
所以其实就是这样子而已
讲解今天的单
好来今天的单
今天的单
这个
在5K
好了
先拉一个不赔
是说才几百块
无所谓
就这样子好了
等一下回来看
我们机会让我补东西
假设等一下
这边回来有东西
这有尖尖的
假设好
那这个东西
我看一下
如果是刚好是这样子
然后尖尖的在这里
假如有
你吃在这边的话
防锁就是尖尖的以外
就这样子
没有什么特别的
那这个是5分K的刻度
那就看你要做哪个K的刻度我今天主要的利润是原油来各位看一下原油老鱼你原油做好多对我主要是底下这边这一段那我先暂时把这些给
我不知道大家有没有看到
来这里从这个看好了
87.41这里
87.41我吃在这附近
做到这边
我吃在这边
这个做到
我看一下书在8917
8917大概在这里
所以这里做了一段
这里做了一段
这些我刚刚都还有截图
我刚刚做到一半的时候的样子
那这边呢
这边有好几次被打掉
这里
但是这前面这边被打掉的时候
其实我是仗着
自己在小那边还有一些获利
等于说我是把那边的获利拿来玩
结果被我玩掉了
这样
好不好
然后像这边
我这边有测试
我这些测试如果你拉到
我先把这关掉好了
这个这样好丑
来
如果你把图拉到60k
你能不能够很清楚的看到
看到我都在60k相对的下缘
那只是今天坦白讲
今天的原油的波动比我平常做原油的波动大好多
所以我其实前面有一段时间我还在习惯这个跳动
你知道吗
所以到后来才慢慢开始习惯他的跳动的刻度
然后比较知道说该怎么防守
虽然说一个刻度一个防守最短最短可能都要300 400
一口原油这样
所以我的做法其实就是在区间里面
所以简单的说
现在的缘由在这个两条线的上半部
并且出现这样子的尖尖的
有没有
所以代表现在这样子短线这里
这个多单
假设这里有尖尖的做多
No No No
这边我就不想做了
所以如果你拉长远来看
我基本上我从这边
我是照着这个边界
下来下不去
弯过来一些嘣试试看
今天主要的利润都是来自于这边然後小娜我記得我好像打一下小娜
記得我有
我前面這段但是中間這段我完全錯過
中午12點整個下午狂噴的這段完全錯過
然後前面這邊先試
然後被打掉這裡
不知道大家看不看得到試一下被打掉
一下被打掉 这里小赔还是不赔 我忘记 我看一下
应该是小赔了 后来在这边测试 这里测试 做到这个地方出场
所以这个地方在很小的地方有才有这种东西 非常小
所以我也就短短的出 后面这一段其实我就没有做到 一直到刚刚
刚刚是仗着我眼前有获利 好了 出去了不应该回来了
那就拉一个不赔
这样子
好不好
然后黄金我今天完全没有碰
来
我其实有点后悔
我没有早一点
也不是真的后悔
就是我没有早一点看到原油
因为我过去这几天
我的交易的心情放得很松
所以我是连晚上的美股
几乎都没有看的
所以前几天的原油
其实很好做
很好做
那MGC你要我现在看什么
5K就在这个边界啊
所以如果要我做多
我不会有想法
做空的人
如果你空在这个边界这里
你就防守这里就好
那看一下60K
60K
坦白讲这个60K对多头比较有利
空头的感觉是
短线会回来没错
但是眼前我看到的力量
是还在往这边堆跌
所以如果是做空的同学不要凹单哦
这一不小心往外打出去
这个很恐怖这样
好不好
对没错
经典赛很松
我的整个心思全部都放在棒球上
所以晚上
整个晚上都在看棒球
然后看完棒球
那个时间也晚了
弄一下小孩干嘛
就准备睡觉
这样
好不好
那我先看一下上面
上面
有同学说TS要求做KYC认证有我有做啊会不会担心个资外流如果你担心就不要传啊
你就不要用这个平台啊
不过坦白讲你在各个平台
其他的坦白讲我不知道
因为我目前用过的就这个
我最近还在试其他的正要试而已
这样
然后我不知道其他会不会做这种身份认证
如果你担心就不要给他嘛
你就不要用这个平台就好
我是不担心啊
因为就我用这个很久了
这样对OK
那打勾的东西等一下我先截起来
待会看可不可以有机会
在盘中找到东西讲
2892第一金我们来看一下
2892第一金你要问我什么
日线是好买点吗
来我们来到日线
如果你问我日线
那我一定会往上一个刻度看一下
我在周线的哪里
请问我在周线的
就最近就好了
上 中 下
请问我在周线的哪里
在中间对不对
那我就不理他了
讲完了
在周线的上 中 下
如果我要做多
我一定是在周线的
唯一就是下
只有下面
但是我也不是來了就吃 好不好
所以眼前的這個地方 我不會有任何興趣
它卡在一個不上不下的中間
如果你退一步看 我對這個29塊不會有想法 好不好
然後同學剛剛問說 台子期小10k現在是標準圖嗎
來 台子期小10k現在不是標準圖
為什麼呢 你可能會認為說是這樣
这里
来我涂鸦给你看了
对不对
这个涂鸦怎么样
你有看到吗
这个涂鸦是长这样子的
所以不要
那你说老鱼这里啊
这个边界啊
如果你是看这个边界
代表你的视野
不见得是单纯60K的视野
可能是更远的视野
那是更远的视野
如果是我
我不喜欢这个东西跟这个东西这样掉下来的样子
所以如果你真的要说标准图
可能要到更短刻度去看看
比如说这个地方 你说本来的压力被这个占上去
这里我比较有话说 下午3点多那时候
所以你刚刚说小时k
如果你用边界的角度说我要摸这个边界
但是纯小时k也不好摸
你可能只能在这边画一条线
然后进到更短刻度里面的相对位置里面
看找到短线有没有东西让你吃
这样
好不好
然后有同学在看旧的影片
我跟大家说不用看到那么旧了
你看这一两年的基本上很够用
如果你这一两年的都看完了
请把心思拉回去给你的老公或老婆
拉回你的家人身上
或许拿去打电动都好
不用再继续看
好不好
今天原油上大損 真的吗我不知道他怎么損 我还没问他
因为我还没去看到他的那个评论
廖大在推荐APEX这个平台
APEX这个平台他是
就我所知他是用那个我过去也很常用Tradleway的这个交易平台
我现在甚至我还是会推荐大家去注册Tradleway免费不用钱
也不用开户不用什么你就是哪个甚至哪个假的email就可以注册
我都会推荐大家去用他的免费重播的功能
然后拿来练习
然后给你两个礼拜的试用期
过了以后你再去用那个10分钟信箱再注册一次
我们都很贼
一直弄到你爽为止这样
目前为止好像都还可以啦
这一招都还可以通用
就占人家这个试用期的便宜
这有点台湾人单小便宜的概念
所以APEX是少數過去啦
因為以前TS只有Traderway
後來TS他自己開發一個新平台
就是我現在在用的這個
他的背後的廠商我記得是ProjectX
你自己Google搜尋都有
總之他的這個平台就是這個
就是現在這個平台
那我是用習慣了
我兩邊都OK
那廖大他用習慣Traderway他就跑去用APEX我过去也曾经用过APEX但我不喜歡他那個動態追尾你現在聽不懂沒有關係你自己Google網路上資料一大堆
所以你問我推不推薦
我不知道耶
這樣子因為我只是不喜歡他的那個動態追尾的功能
有的人很喜歡啊
我覺得OK啊這樣
這間公司好或壞
坦白講我沒有辦法完全去評論
如果廖大在推薦我覺得
你要用就ok啊
那就试着出镜看看嘛
对不对
这样
如果你发现他出镜有问题
你就不要用他
这样子就好了
我晚一点我来关心一下廖大
原油
他只说风控很大而已
他说风控很大
这个我有看到啊
是真的
原油随便一个风控
来
例如说我现在开原油
随便一个封控
例如说
原油
我先把那个拿掉
那个好爱眼
假设我要在这里做多
不要做
拜托不要做
这个60k上影线这么尖
千万不要在这里做多
好吧
我只是假设
假设我要在这里做多
一个5分k要守到
好远哦
这样子要1000美金
千万不要在这里做多
拜托
好不好
你如果要做多以前
请你看一下
这个60K长这样子
现在8点59代表
9点钟要到了
所以这个60K基本上就收这样
所以收这样子
收这样子的60分K
代表接下来这个小时
往这边走的几率高很多
就算它往这边喷出去
都不关我的事我就不要做了
这样
所以我少说要忍一个小时少说
这样可以吗
如果你要做多的这个
千万不要
好不好
我很讨厌看到
我要做多的时候
然后我的对面就是
刚刚这样子60k是长这样
这我很不喜欢
OK
然后
因为时差都是看回放
这位同学你是住在哪边有时差你是住在国外的吗如果住国外现在是你的应该是早上6点或5点
太强了
好不好
M&Q
对我的M&Q我都忘记了
我都忘记我M&Q
15分K
出现破底翻是做空的标准图吗
等一下15分K
来通常这种我们如果是空方的
我们会讲假突破
来我问你哦
你把这个放在心中
我涂鸦给你看
从你刚刚下单的时候
15分可以在这里吗
尖尖的
我涂鸦给你看
看有没有跟他一样
注意看哦
我把端点都这样涂鸦
请问
在最近期的这个地方
有出现这个东西吗
有吗
没有吧
对吧
最近期的15k在这里
我的涂鸦告诉我
跌多涨少
但是这边有没有开始出现跌不多
这就是我下单的想法
跌不多以后涨
涨多了
你怎么在这里做空
对吧
不行不行不行
这样可以吗
那有同学说
最近波动那么大
是不是不要那么快拉不赔
哦没有
我反而喜欢快速拉不赔
为什么
就因为波动大
所以我很快被拉不赔
反正我人在盘前
了不起我就重来就好了
我人在盘前
我就坐在这里啊
对吧
我宁愿被点掉
波动大的坏处
就是你例如说我风险拉到
拉到某个地方比较远
波动大就是你拉多远
它都会中
对吧
你拉多久都会中
我不如就很快速的先用个不赔
一旦我不赔以后
波动再怎么大
都跟我无关
你知道我那一瞬间
我把波动大这个变因
拿掉了
在我的字典里面没有波动大
我很快速的咻拉不赔
很快速的咻拉不赔
有种就来打我
这样
有没有可能拉了不赔
结果三分钟后下来
把我点掉就喷出
好 点掉篇图我认了
反正我刚刚就没有下单嘛
懂这个想法对不对好不好我有试过在波动大的时候试着放大一些风控来跟他玩但我发现不行
因为坡洞太大
所以你一放大风控打一次就好痛
来我问一下旁边的各位
你有被这种大坡洞
你拉远距离的停顺
但是因为他太大了
还是被打到的拘手
你有这样的经验拘手
痛不痛
有没有很慢
就是你会瞬间亏一笔比你平常能够忍受的挺损
例如说原油好了
原油现在随便一个风险
要一口原油要拉到500美金的那个颗度
所以也因为这样子
所以我很快速的拉不赔
等一下我有把我中间交易的过程
我留起来给大家
好不好
那我看一下这个Wolf
然后我等一下就来讲一下今天的东西
好吗
来到我们Wolf
我看一下Wolf是什么
这个Wolf Speed
我是不是每天都会有下单
没有我昨天一整天白天到晚上完全没下单
完全没有
甚至我最近几乎
那个美盘的股票
我碰都没有碰
最近
已经这一个月的吧
我都没有碰
一方面是冬令时间
一方面是我之前才
才跟老婆吵架爆料过
所以我现在其实晚上就
算了就不碰了
就乖乖的
来Wolf
盘前在
我用这边看好了
Wolf
因為這邊我看得到全貌
我看一下
AWARF其實不錯耶
日線這些邊界可以喔
我看一下周線
周線你心裡要有底
他後面在這邊繼續震盪的機率
會比較高一些些
為什麼會這樣講?因為前面這裡太兇了
那所以你心裡面就知道日線你要吃不要吃太高
你就慢慢的等他會在這附近來回的震盪震盪震盪
這樣子因為這邊又有這個東西
如果我是你像現在空手的話
我會稍微保守一點點部位小一點
然後抓他可能還會回來測這個邊界的心理的計畫
然後往後做這樣
ok
有東西說小娜有點沒力是不是
我看一下
對啊有點沒力了
有點沒力
好啦管他了
反正我都已經是
我都已經是有賺錢了 我現在就這樣子
好不好
來 那我暫時先
先把同學的問題我先截起來
因為同學字比較多 可能等一下要花時間看一下
讓我先來
先來在
今天的主題裡面講
等一下主題講一講 大概九點半多
應該還是會有時間跟大家聊天
好不好
ZigZag那個叫做什麼線
反正就鋸齒狀的那個線
我不知道它的中文翻譯叫什麼
那其實它也是可以
它就是把行情縮成
就是這種只剩一條線這樣
我是已經很習慣直接看圖
看K棒的樣子
OK
來那我先
我先繼續往後面
所以今天的這個主題
不是我自己想到要这样问的
这个是某个网友
然后他问的问题
然后同学呢
他问说老鱼你做了什么不一样的事情
才成为成功的交易者
要怎么做
该怎么做才可以跟老鱼一样
来
那我们就先来聊今天的课程
第一个你要先定义一下
你口中的这个成功到底是什么
是明吗
是利吗
那这也是为什么
我从来不
我不认为我是成功的吹的
我都还会乱掉
我在一个月前才乱掉
然后跟老婆大吵等等
我还是会啊
所以我不认为我是成功的吹的
我只认为我是运气好
侥幸在市场上还活着的吹的
我到目前为止
我都还是认为市场的能力是无限大
然后我在市场前面我只是小蚂蚁一只
不管我赚多少钱我都只是小蚂蚁一只我只是趁机刚好看到某些点也可以下单来试着读读看就这样子
所以如果你口中的成功是名跟利
那很有可能你是活在别人的世界里
所以实际上是我从来没有想过我到底是成功的Trader
还是不成功的Trader
成功也好不成功也好管他的
反正悶起头来我自己做我自己的事情
那你就要想成功这个定义是社会上谁贴出来的标签
这样子到底是谁贴出来的标签
是你吗
是你身边的爸爸妈妈吗
还是你身边的同学参加同学会的时候
哇 谁好成功喔
谁去美国念书
哇 谁怎么样
谁在美国发展的很好
谁开了一间公司
哇 赚多少钱多少钱
我讲一个实际的案例
我们还有一些同学会聚会
就以前的小时候的同学
那有几个同学他们很喜欢聊天的时候
例如说我们讲到股票
他说 强者我同学 强者我朋友 都不是他自己
反正他就会讲一个 我跟你说 你赚100万
我跟你说 我那个朋友他赚1000
讲到房地产 我跟你说 我那个朋友 另外一个朋友
房地产赚好多 就是都不是他自己
讲到学业 那个谁谁谁很会念书
现在在美国NASA里面
讲来讲去他就是要讲到一个
强者我朋友来把当下的米给比下去
那一次同学会两次同学会
十年过去了
我们的发展好像慢慢在往上走
结果那位同学的发展好像留在
他一开始的那个位置
就是这十年过去了
这样
那他的那些强者都继续当强者
但是他自己却没有因为那些人很成功吗
很厉害吗
而变得更厉害
因为他的视野都摆在外界
甚至有人比他强的时候或是他很自卑的感觉出来的时候他就会拿这些人出来讲来隐藏自己的自卑感你身边有没有这种朋友
应该有对不对
对吧
只是你也懒得戳破他
你只是会久而久之
就是到现在就是不联络了
因为每次去跟他讲话
就强着我同学
强着我朋友
甚至讲到那个什么
什么红灯区
去日本哪些地方有一些有什么特别的事情
他也会说强者我朋友
干嘛干嘛干嘛
我觉得这个强者就是他自己
好不好
所以有同学问说
要怎么当成功的交易者
我跟你说
要当成功的交易者
假设你是只赚得到钱的
你必须要先把
要当成功的交易者这句话
完全的拿出脑袋
就是你要跟市场讲
跟网路上的所有人说
甚至我现在就跟所有的网友讲
他妈的我自己的单子
我自己扛
我的交易做的好做的坏
关你什么事
为什么需要你来评论我
我成功也好不成功也好
我自己的事情
对吧
一个成功的交易者
你去看网路上的这些
厉害的大神们
没有人鳥你 你去怎么讲他都无所谓 他才不管你了
懂吗 所以你必须要先具备一个这种天塌下来
你都不理他的这种心态
ok 再来
我曾经做了哪些不一样的事 因为同学问的是问
我做的哪些不一样的事才成为一个成功的吹德
所以第一個是我說我不怎麼在乎別人對不對
來
我在小時候20初頭歲那時候剛開始跟我老婆交往
後來我們結婚了然後生小孩
那時候生了小孩以後還住在媽媽家裡面
就住在長輩嘛
很自然的因為住家裡省了房租嘛
但是那时候反正因缘际会毅然决然在很没钱的时候就硬是搬出来
我还记得我第一个住的那种房子是我们的厨房也不是厨房那个房东他只是在一个就是房间房间外面的走道摆一个那种卡式炉就是我们现在露营在用的那种
小小的一个瓦斯炉
然后我记得那个好像
不是瓦斯
那个是电磁炉的样子
反正没有明火
不用用瓦斯就用电磁炉这样
然后旁边一个
那个什么
北TR的洗手台
洗手台
然后电磁炉
那就是我的厨房
这样
然后有两个房间
然后那时候住的地方靠缝甲
那里就是冬天那个风有够冷
风会从窗户灌进来
这样
然后呢
那个时候反正就是在很没钱的时候
就是硬是把自己的生活费自己扛下来
这样
然后刚搬出来自己扛的时候有点后悔
因为住家里不用房租嘛
一出来就要房租啦
房租我记得是多少
一万三
讲我记得没错的话
一万三这样
对啊
所以很惨
然后后来还跑去开了咖啡厅
这个过去也都讲过这些故事
那后来倒掉了东西还是二手
我们直接叫那些估价的来
二手直接估一估
买都是好几万好几十万以上哦
再买
然后卖的时候是论金乘两
几千块
原价可能五万块的东西
他估两千块收走
对就是这样
不然你就堆在这
你自己处理
然后
我也参加过直销
然后我没赚到钱
不过我倒是练在直销里面
练就了现在可以跟大家口若悬河的能力
黑的讲成白的
白的讲成黑的的能力
那段因为有机会在直销的场合里面在台上讲
所以就那段过程我也不会觉得说他是不好
他就只是我没有赚到钱
可能还花了很多钱
这样
那我的学到的东西就只是我的可能演讲的能力
讲是在那个时候摸起来的
然后后来
反正我后来生了两个小孩
负债一大堆
然后
我跑去找了一个工作
那个工作是什么
一个反正很乱七八糟的工作
我自己的我之前都还有讲给大家看过
那反正我就相信那个老板
他应征叫做什么
行销的主管
薪水六万块
那时候我很没有钱
很没有钱的时候
你在找工作
一般薪水都是三万多块
三万多块
可能网路行销
行销企划
两万八
三万二
然后突然间来一个6万
然后这时候我就认为说
我自己终于有一个地方让我发挥了
一去他就说我要付14000的就业的什么
上课的费用
他说什么之后政府会退给我们
所以我只是先缴
之后通过认证什么政府会退
我跟各位说
你去上班千万不要缴任何的钱
一毛都不需要交给他
你是去上班的
好不好
我就做了这种事情
所以我还给他钱
然后做了四个月的白工
就这样子
很惨
我们到最后还去跑去找
我说过找那个
找
那个什么政府的
有一个基金
那个叫什么
薪资电厂
老保里面有一个薪资代厂
反正我就跑到最后一关
他需要老板签和
说我真的欠了你们这些人
我们大概有十几二十个人
大家一起集合
老板要签说
我承认这些债权
这样欠你们签
签了政府才会代替这个老板
先把薪水拨给你
然后政府再去跟老板要签
但是老板就找不到人了
纯正信行也进不到了
就电话不接
然后那个地址人就不见了
我怎么找得到人签啊
这样好不好
然后某个程度来说
我从小到大
我做了一些比较
人家讲背骨
比较背骨
跟长辈要的这种安全牌是不一样的
所以我根本不是财经背景
我是念放射科的
S光有没有
你去醫院抱著一個機器吸氣不要吐氣喔然後外面的祭司關门按下去几秒钟后好了有没有对就是这个我以前是念放射科的
所以廖大是我放射科的同学
他也是放射科的
他甚至是还有在医院职业过
我是毕业后就完全没有进去医院
只有在麻洁医院实习过而已
所以我不是这个背景
却走入股市
那我曾经很在乎别人的眼光
因为很穷嘛
很穷的时候你就想要快一点
被谁
被同学认同
被爸爸妈妈认同
我没有爸爸
被妈妈认同
然后被亲戚朋友认同
被长辈认同
反正各种
我活在别人的世界里
所以我要求快
所以我会身边就会开始出现各种
各种投机取消的人
而我现在回头过来看那段过程
原来那些投机取消
想要把我的钱A走的人
是我自己吸来的
因为当时的我
我的脑袋里满脑子想的都是快钱
各种奇奇怪怪的快钱
这是反骨不是背骨
对不起
我其实没有很懂
所以那些人事物一直到现在好了
我过去这十年吗
这十几年来
我发现我身边这种奇怪的人都不见了
好奇怪
我去咖啡厅明明还是会听到旁边在聊
聊一些比较投机的东西
聊可能是虚拟货币的诈骗的
我都听得出来
他们都会讲得很大声
然后都会说这个很棒很棒
然后每个月零多少钱这样
然后其实但是我的生活中
跟我认识的也好
怎么样也好
我出去外面也好
怎么这种人都不见了
原来是我现在脑袋里的
这样子的思想已经不一样了
所以自然而然就不会吸引这一类的人来到我的生命中
所以我就比较不会去踩雷
我以前踩超多的各种地雷那包含交易其实也是我最一开始的交易谁不是想要赚钱你也是我也是大家都是
所以我一定是想要求快
最快的方式就是选择权期货
直接按下去哇瞬间钱就来了
但是那种感觉
你会上瘾
所以上瘾以后你的脑袋子满脑子都是那些东西
那自然而然你所做出來的交易
就會變得很急躁
很快
越做越短
本來做長線越做越短越做越短這樣
ok
然後呢
那時候我很窮
也負債
所以我一直認為
認為說我明明就
就是我長得一表人才對不對
然後
然後怎麼我的能力也不會太
又好像自己應該腦袋不會太差
怎麼我的薪水只有這樣子
然後開始怪外界的事情這樣
你身邊有沒有遇過一些人
交易做不好開始怪政府
怪國安基金沒有護盤
怪大戶怎麼樣
怪籌碼怎麼樣
怪東怪西
怪那間公司的老闆怎麼樣
全部都怪了都沒有怪他自己
對吧
我就是後來
我说我甘于现状
甘于现状的概念是什么
其实我不是被迫
被迫放下那个自尊跟自傲
我不是说我以前觉得自己很厉害吗
我应该要很强啊
所以求快对不对
我是被迫放下的
为什么被迫
因为没有钱了
我去做期货交易
一开始赚到钱也很快的赔到钱
而且甚至还变成富的
然後後來有小孩以後生活費的壓力很大
所以就是整個負債越滾越大
那時候我還有信用卡的卡在
那個18%的信用卡的循環利息
我繳過很恐怖很恐怖
所以那時候同學說的對
我其實當時是有點放棄的躺平
我只好甘於現狀這樣
但是或许就因为那段时间
我并不想要快速成长
我想说好了我把我眼前做的事情我不管什么工作反正我当时在做的那个事情我先把它做好然后也很感谢我老婆在那个时候他的保险的工作
撑起了我们家的经济跟收入
还可以让我们开始存到一点钱
所以很多负债是他那时候开始还
然后后来我才有机会从小台慢慢做
慢慢做这样
所以人生跟交易是一样的
是每个选择都是单行道
这句话我最近在看那个
你说那时候是几岁
20出头岁
但是我精确讲几岁
我没有办法精准的讲
因为在我的人生里面
20岁到30岁这个阶段
是很浑浑噩噩
做了很多事情
但是就是各种亏钱啊
干嘛的
我现在回头去想
那段日子好痛苦
可能我的脑袋自动去屏蔽那些很痛苦的感觉
我最近在看那个郑宗哲
他是台湾队里面很厉害很厉害的那一首
我看他的那个podcast的访问
刚好讲到一个说什么
人生就像单行道一样
他就是没有办法重来
没错
所以我们只是试着把当下的选择
我举个例子假设你现在是高三升
你即将面临考试甚至或是说你已经考过了
对吧考过那个学册
你要选大学
我到底是要选这间大学好还是这间大学好
我跟你说都好
选你当下你的心想要的那个这样就对了
然后重点是你选了以后你不要三心二意
你都选了一个大学了对不对
你就好好的把那个科系那个东西给它念过去
喜欢也好也不喜欢也好
你就给他念过去
就这样
然后你就试着把那个当下的做好
如果当下你不喜欢
好啊
你不要那个当下你不喜欢那个学校
休学嘛
退学嘛
换一间嘛
如果不要你出来工作嘛
OK啊
自己的选择
你是不是又做了第二个选择了
又是第二个担心到
你休学跑去工作
OK啊
那就去工作
好好的把你的工作给做好
对吧
所以当下但是太多做交易的人
舍不得放在当下他永远都在
過去裡面找自己
例如說NQ
習慣原有的跳動以後回來看NQ
你會覺得可能是因為我只下五口的關係
好來
那個
你看很多人會回到過去
例如說這邊老魚我剛剛在這裡應該下單的
老魚我剛剛在這裡應該下單的
他永远一直在过去寻找自己的交易
那对我来讲
我从来不在过去寻找说哪里可以下单
哪里不能下单
因为只要我一做
我就会进入一个FOMO
Fear of missing out
害怕错过的那种行情
因为我曾经错过了
对吧
所以我现在就更害怕错过
那更害怕错过的唯一方法就是追
就是做出各种不符合我本来在做交易的
的这个样子
懂这个想法吗
所以我是把交易
对我来讲我每一次打开行情
原油是原油现在的样子
例如说原油
现在的样子
然后小纳有小纳现在的样子
黄金也喷了吗
黄金这个点很好
坦白说
黃金
黃金15k或是5k底下這邊
5180這附近
對如果在5k甚至有機會在5175這附近吃到東西
有吃到的各位滿足區
這個從5k來看是滿足區
好不好
但是我這邊都沒有做到
我就只有小納就這樣就好了
同学说老鱼你的第一句话是问我该做什么才能跟老鱼一样
重点是你用了该这件事情
我这边先跳开来讲
各位没有该不该
如果有讲这个该做什么
我就说来赶快先升
你应该要先升三个
然后先跟我一样很苦很苦很苦才能爬上来
不是吧 对吧来 举个例子这是真实的我儿子说他想成为第二个大谷祥品然后他想要进去大联盟
想要跟大谷祥品一起打球
当他的队友
然后也要双刀流
然后年薪也要跟他一样
各位请问大家
来请换你给我意见
我该怎么做
才可以让我儿子做到
你现在听得懂我的意思了吗
如果你是请各位用在threads上面
在tray上面的那种酸言酸语的方式
来酸这个发文
你会怎么酸它
我其实蛮想看一下的
对吧
那我还特别去买了这本书
这本书就在
在在在
在哪里
我忘记了
他在旁边
我还特别跑去买了这本书
然后请他去睡觉
睡吧
梦里什么东西
对吧
你是不是就是这样讲
来
这本书里面有各种大古
祥品打全雷打的知识
对不对
抓住大古
这个有点难
先送去花卷东
把梦想写下来
所以我说
所以我问你
买了这本了
这本已经有全雷达各种知识的解剖
它分析的很细
真的很细
我真的买回来看
我翻了一下
哇好棒
所以我看了这个
我就能够复制大股详品的全雷达
真的可以吗
全大联盟每一个打者都想要学他的打击方法
然后都想要学三本游身拿那个标枪的头
对吧
但是我个人认为
如果要成为大谷
我们可能要先去住在火星上
我不觉得大谷是地球人
我觉得他是外星人
他的所有的数据都太扯
他是外星人 對吧
所以我不想要
我真實的我啦我不覺得我可以成為大股但是各位有沒有看過大股祥品他有一个九宫格我就不Google了我就不找给大家看
大家他有个九宫格的这个
他的目标
然后还有延伸出81宫格
大家有看过那个吗
应该都有吧
对不对
我们虽然无法复制大股祥品的打击知识
但是我们可以复制他的态度
他设定目标的方法
他的观念
所以各位
各位来
该做什么才能跟老鱼一样
你要做的
其实不是想要跟我一样
你要做的其实是把这个观念
拉回到你的人生里面
你的人生里面
你专注在你自己的交易计划
你的人生计划
你的赚赔也好
等等也好
这个才是你要专注的东西
你的生活
你的家庭
那你自然而然会发展出属于你的样子
你不需要成为大股强品
你也不需要变得跟老鱼一样
跟我一样没有比较好
没有
对吧
没错
每个人都是独立的个体
所以黄金
你看
对
NQ满足了吗
NQ喷出了
我看一下60k
稍微随便拉一下
60k还在喷
可以读一下
我希望他可不可以创高这边走一下
所以出场点随便拉一下
好了
既然这样就出场一下好了
没感觉
好了出一下
来
所以
这边
所以不需要想要成为牢狱
不用
你有你的特色
你有你的优点
那你反而要练习的是
学我不在乎别人的想法的这件事情
来
我接下来要聊的就是这些
我做对几件事情
其中一个很重要的就是
我不怎么在乎别人的想法
我曾经很在乎
所以我前面的世界里面
人家说
像我们小时候
每个男生应该都会
很会重灌那个Windows记得吧那时候Windows大家都有一片光碟对吧然后从XP开始一路这样子
然后windows XP
windows
天啊
windows95
我从windows95
我从windows3.1开始玩
然后我还会组装电脑
会自己装CPU
然后涂散热膏
那个年代
大家都去台中那个电子街玩过
对不对
我会
所以人家就说
你应该走电脑这条路
我曾经去帮人家重灌电脑修电脑过
你英文很好
你国外回来的应该去教英文
我也去教过儿童梅语
我还当过人家的家教
我还当过几位大姐
当时我20出头岁
然后几位40、50岁的大姐
我去教他们怎么用email啊
用什么的这样
总之
这些都是人家说的
甚至还有那个庙里的技工师傅掐指一算
你去跟着那位师兄做房地产
这样
我就哦好
我就跑去做房地产
我当了两到三个月的会双房屋的仲介
房仲这样子
我没有考到那个什么房屋的
那个段时间就是骑着摩托车到处去扫街干嘛的这样
反正我做了很多事情
都是因为我在乎别人的事情
所以人家说A我就做A
说B我就做B
我一直都没有遵循我自己内心真正的想法
那我自己内心真正的想法是什么
我去到任何一个地方
我还去连聚建设
当过一个月不到
我就辞职了
一个月不到的那种行销助理
就是想要进去帮忙卖房子干嘛的这样
那我还跟他挨了一个
刚好遇到过年
他还送了我一把连锯的大雨伞
这样
有同学说再讲一次做几个
我做过17种不同的工作
然后呢
我是我刚刚说过
我是念放射课出身
所以我是一个非财经背景
我根本不是念金融相關科系的
所以呢
我一進去
我到時候跑去當那個
我在華南期貨當營業員的時候
因為當時我其實已經剛開始會交易
剛開始
所以我認為我的
交易法可以可以教人家
如果我可以教客户
那客户就比较不会挂掉
赚得到钱
那一个客户留下来
两个客户三个客户
久而久之
我应该就可以有比较多的客户
好好好
我的想法是这样
就后来都是大家跟我学
跑去下别间
因为很简单
因为别人手续费比较便宜
那时候就变这样
反正各种主管
或是资深营业员
做了10年20年的营业员
或是大主管
就是一些前一个世代的大主管
很厉害的那些
他们都跑来跟我讲说
营业员要考证照
所以要考一张叫做
像我去期货公司上班
你要有一张期货商业务员
不是分析师
分析师是另外一件事情
是期货的业务员的证照
连那个接电话的总机小姐
他都需要有
期货商业务员的证照
这样
所以我就只是去考了那个证照
那个备考古题就好
备一备去写一写就过了
两个礼拜就可以过了
这样子
反正他们跟我讲这些
你只会这一招
没有用
我一出场就跌了吗
真的吗
哈哈
耶
对吧
然后他们也要求我去懂那个总体经济
要看学会看财报看筹码
然后要我去考分析师等等
讲到分析师我一直都有讲
我有去考但没有考过
分析师太难了
那个考那个有一个科目叫做什么
总体经济
总体经济那个科目是没有范围的
就是任何跟经济有关的东西
他的题目大概是这样
请用某某某曲线
某某公式计算
当什么东西为1
什么东西为0的时候的利率
怎么样怎么样
会变成多少
然后深论题请做图
做什么
我看到就睡着了
但是那些批评我
只有一个方法的人
他到现在已经就我所知他已经不在这个市场上了这样但是这这么多年来我还活着而且我不知道这边有没有那些听我们的课听好几年的同学
我记得有
你自己看这么多年来我是不是都是用着同一件事情
同一个方法这样因为眼前的东西就有用啊
有用我干嘛换
那我不懂总金没关系啊
价格会说话啊
包含原油的大涨大跌
川普说战争要结束
原油明明就上面有很多地方
就告诉你上不去
所以我做了一些
跟旁边的人给我的意见不一样的事
人家跟我说这些
我就说好好好
我也没有反驳他
我就只是嘴巴说好
然后现在怎么样
嘴巴说好
我就自己做的
反正我也懶得去跟他辩论
我就这样子
所以到现在就变成这样子
来聊一下
这个是我在今天的五点多那时候
我的截图这样
那注意看
这是我在原油的1分K
当时的利润只有4000多
我人在外面
五点多嘛
所以我用手机吃
我吃在这个地方这里
我的防守就这样子而已
来给刚刚同学说
勾起来大概是什么样子
就是这里
这个惯性下来
弯起来的
好我在弯起来这边下单手
但是我不是单纯只有看EK
我的脑袋里面
其实是有更大刻度的样子
这样知道我的意思吗
我的脑袋都有
我只是要讲我的防守就这样子
这已经是极限了
那你说老鱼你为什么做1k
因为如果今天的行情我要做5分k
我随便一个防守都要500到1000美金
我不喜欢承受到那么大一口单的防守
所以我只好退而求其次
我进到更小的科度
去看有没有我要的东西
这样
所以你看这两张相隔应该不用一分钟
这一张跟这一张我做了一个
对打勾就是惯性改变就是本来跌多长少叠多长少变成涨多了所以这个时候回来如果他跌少我就可以下单不就是本来跌多长少 变成长多了所以这个时候回来如果它跌少我就可以下单 不就是我们的破底盘
对不对
然后呢看一下这两张
我特别把这两张结起来
因为我觉得我想要留下一些
我下单过程中我看到的东西以及我的动作
我有没有很快速的拉了一个不赔
這兩個箱它才一分鐘
來請仔細看一下
來請告訴我
這裡跟這裡哪裡不一樣
是不是這個東西有突出去了
這裡對吧
本來還沒有突出去
它突出去了對吧
所以它一旦突出去了
在我的腦袋裡面
它就不應該回來
對吧
他不应该回来啦
回来太远了
而且这时候我的未平仓已经有760
所以我保护一下
用30块钱保护我的这些利润
不要让他变成亏钱的
我可能下一秒钟像这个一样
几分钟之后咻打下来
哎呀只赚30块
好重来重来
对吧
这就是真实
这是今天下午的事情
大家看到这个应该明显知道我在干嘛
对吧
我很习惯这样子
只要行情整理了
出去了
不管他出多远
他出去了
他就不应该回来
所以我就把我的风险拉掉
所以像我刚刚小娜
哎呦运气好
我刚刚小娜我在这边吃
吃完以后来到这里
来到这边
这附近这附近
我就差不多就可以
把我的风险拉掉
我好像是在大家眼前拉的
还是怎么样
好像是吧
对不对
对呀
我的想法就很简单
就是他只要上來整理過
再出去一次
風險就拿掉
他不應該再回來
像現在
來
看一下這個小10k
哇
這個小10k這樣子很醜很醜
好不好
原油勒
哦來來來來來
比在哪裡
我的比勒
比
我問一下剛剛一開始你們有講在這個地方我有沒有說了我說這個東西出現這樣子隔壁這邊我還有画图我说当时我说这边往下走的几率很高所以我至少要忍一个小时
有没有
老于在说你有没有在听
所以我刚刚是不是说
我刚刚有没有说这边有这个机会
我跟大家讲说千万不要下桌单
有没有
你看你看你看
对吧
这就是我对市场的解读
我没有很厉害
是因为我看了这个上影线
太多次了
多到我百分之百信赖这个东西
就算它可能偶尔会出现不一样的行情
都没关系
就是那个百分之百的信赖
所以我又再度的跟大家说
拜托拜托
下单以前假设你要做5K或15K的单子
请你往上看一下更大颗度的
可以吗
你就突然间发现后面那个是声控的是不是
它可以变成声控
它也可以换不同颜色
它自己飘的这样子
OK
来
再来
后面还有这个时候
当时的部位
当时好像在这边
这边我不是说我做完了吗
刚刚有跟大家讲
所以做完了以后累积到6666
我又做了一个新部位
这里这里这里
我可以直接开啊
开给大家看
一样在EK
对这是EK
来来来来来来来来来
再来在这里
在这里
前面那个就是在这边
在在在这边
然后这样桌上去
这边还有一个
这边桌上去
有没有
不对对不起
这边这个是不赔打掉
吃在92
卖在95
所以没有赚到钱
这个偷摸不赔打掉
这边又重新摸回来
76然后出在8917
这样子
注意看
来
我运气我出在90.93
90.93在这里
在几乎是高点的地方
所以我可以
我运气好从这边做到
這邊,出完就下來了
好開心
你知道我覺得這輩子最開心的事情就是這樣
就是你吃了开始出去
然后你一出掉拜拜就下来
多好
对不对
大家一定要都体会过这种爽快的感觉对吧
来所以我这张单子就是这张单子就是这张
那你看我当时所承受的风险又来一次
我吃在这个地方
防守这里这就是这张就是我回到当下好了
我放大一点
给大家看
回到1k
这1k可以吃
可以300可以啦
来回到当下
反正刚刚小纳我赚钱
300而已给他给他
我吃在1分k的这边
我吃在这边
然后呢
出在这里对吧
我当时的风险就是就像现在一样
OK
所以现在亏120
120亏了就这样子
停损后才说
我也有可能停损
我等一下可能把我停损
停损我就亏300
亏了
有没有关系
没有关系
亏了以后我就知道
来到大一个科度
亏了以后
原来这边是这样下来
好我不要乱按了
对吧
或许今天就这样子睡觉也可以
好 那就把它锁起来 锁整天 锁住 好啦 不让我按了
好 就这样子 刚刚完失败 完失败就锁起来 不完了
按这边有没有新的机会 有 但是我锁起来 我不想做
这样就好 OK
所以我当时这是在 7点14分的时候
我做这个单子 我想说刚好我一按
我一按 趕快解給大家看
因為同學一定會想要知道
我是在怎麼地方防守的 對吧
來
我看一下這位同學
怎麼看大科都對我不利的地方
喔 剛好啊 剛剛的原油 來來來來
剛剛的
刚刚的原油的这里
现在的原油也是不好我知道不好因为现在的60分K并不是我喜欢的我喜欢的60K是这样子
我个人觉得最好做
假设现在9点47
9点47假设K棒收这样子的隔壁
这个会比较好做
或是这根这样子
下一个小时再杀一根
下一个小时开在这边
很用力的往下杀
又縮回來變成這樣子
出現這樣子的
再下一個小時所以會是
12點
現在10點
11點多
的那個時候大概會在這個地方
我的前面是60分可以長這樣子的可以放在這裡
我會很喜歡下多單
這樣知道意思嗎
所以我剛剛其實很明確的知道
我在投摸我是拿着杖子有获利
我在投摸摸失败了好了不要玩
我又怕我进入到那个乱七八糟的状态
就直接锁住就好了
对
懂我的想法吗
而且
大科度上缘
如果你是刚刚想在这边做多的
这就是一个
不利的地方这样看得懂了吗
好不好
有同学下了NQ的空单是不是
我们来看一下
NQ的空单
计划赚300点左右
你是指300点是指往下赚300点吗
我看一下哦
哦你想要赚到这边对不对
说不定可以赚成功哦
不错啊
我是不知道你是用哪一个刻度赚的
对啊
那我不确定你在哪一根地方做空单
不过目前看起来有点危险
要小心哦
昨天晚上10.05分
GC的情况会怎么处理
这么明确啊
10.05
所以你应该是5分K
昨天晚上
昨天
你讲的是这里吗
10.05会怎么处理是不是
是不是
这个
我们回到当下来这里你是不是抓出边界如果你有在这个地方吃尖尖的隔壁吃这个我觉得是我认同的点
OK但是如果你是在隔壁这里来注意看
注意看
我的我的等一下我把它拉过来一点
我的大头不要挡到
来
眼睛看一下这边
如果你是在这一根的隔壁
开在这边一路往下走的过程中
你在这个地方吃
你心里要有底
这个单子很容易被打掉
因为在吃单的当下
这根K棒的惯性是由上
而且是由上面比较高的位阶
带着位移的动能
这个以物理学来讲
这个叫未能
未知改变的这个能量
它带着未知改变的能量往下冲
这个能量很有可能会把你继续往下冲
所以我喜欢做的是做在十字线
这个K棒是停顿的概念
它已经往下冲过了市场停住了
这样子的隔壁我愿意做
所以这个不好做
像我刚刚的那个原油
就是这样子打掉的
有没有
然后这一根
假设你有下单好了
你有下单在这边
你可能被不赔打掉
或是亏损打掉都没关系
了不起小赔
出现这样子
你再度规划一下
原来打急区在这个框框
那如果是这样子
你的防守
你再怎么样防守
要把整块
整块给防进去
你就要衡量一下了
我如果吃在这个地方
那你很有可能会被这个点掉
会哦
只是我不确定你是在这一根
一开始就吃先被点掉
还是你是等它下去回来再吃
然后没有被点掉
这个我不敢说
这样
那我也不晓得我会不会吃得到
但是我不会守到这个
吃这边守到这边会觉得太远了
这样子
所以说不定我会亏一次亏两次
然后没有赚到这一波
对
比较有可能
然后说不定是后面这边才找到东西吃吧
但是这个都事后论了啦这样
好不好有同学说我好像有变瘦吗IB没有做
我最近IB很少碰
的另外一个原因
是我前一段时间
我说我跟老婆
我说我整年度都在
都在打棒球
然后忽略了老婆等等这些
所以整个冬令时间
对我来讲不是很友善
现在终于变夏令
到现在才变夏令时间
所以终于在9点多开始有开盘
所以我或许可以开始比较拉回来
这样
不然其实我本来也很想要见6月份的仓位
这样子
看到IEO会怎么做交易计划
举个例子
例如说我们就刚刚的原油好了
原油5分K
这个上影线要做多的人
不要乱来哦
好不好
这个还蛮凶的样子
不要乱来
好吗
例如说我会怎么做交易计划
例如说
早上的时候
早上10点这附近
我会先看过60分K的样子
假设有一个60分K长在这里
这样子好不好
那其实我最喜欢的
假设它杀深一点
如果他殺到86這裡
然後盤中很凶的跌破86
瞬間從85這邊收回來留了一個
一個跌破這個邊界的下影線在外面
他要收回這裡面
這個概念就跟剛剛的那個AMD同學的AMD很像
有沒有
如果這種我就會把這邊
把
這裡
把這裡
如果有
K棒大概長這樣子好了
如果他有這樣子咻的插下來
我會把這個東西的隔壁例如說86塊這裡
列為
列為我密切觀察的地方
那我現在在60分K
所以到時候我就會進到
到時候的5分K裡面去
那86在這
對吧
所以假設行情是這樣子
是這個可以借我用
我就可以进到
我觉得这个叠得不够多
这样子好了
这样可以这样
这样他很用力的跌破了
那我来到短线
假设我短线看到这样子
市场是这样子下来
来到这个地方
我短线看到这样
我的计划很简单
我就画出一个惯性改变的样子
然后呢
弄个半透明的图
跌在这个上面
好了
那这时候行情就会这样走来走去
走来走去对不对
我就等
那我看是我要在1分K里等
还是在5分K里等
以眼前的原油来说
可能要到1K
才有那个小封控的地方
如果5K封控没有办法
它图就是这么大
这样
OK
所以其实就是
如果有我用画的
假设这边
在短刻度里
我就等这个东西发生
这个概念
而这个图跟这张
你有没有看到我下单在这边
我是因为他下来了
原油突然间出现大量杀很多
照道理讲隔壁要继续杀才对
结果居然没有继续杀
我等了一个好几分钟等了5分K
所以这里其实我有看过5K的样子
对吧
这样
所以我想说好
而且当时注意看
我当时有6000多
我能不能够赔个310
賠了300億有感覺嗎?沒感覺,完!
這就是我講的,我拿著當天額外的子彈
繼續拿出來打,對不對?打輸了我還是6000多回家
打贏了,又再加個兩三千,Oh yeah!
這樣知道這個想法嗎?
好不好?
如果小10k不是落在那同一根這個像影線
还是因为小10k不再感
不是我阅读一下你的文字
等一下
同一根这个一个下影线K棒
哦好来我大概看懂你的意思
就像是现在的这个小10k这个
对吧
不是落在干净
干净边缘在这边
他没有落在干净边缘
大概就像现在这样子同一根这个下引线假设同一根开始出现这样子的所以这个时候你会在短刻度里的5K看到小小的这样子对吧
你就吃啊就接受啊
就算
他亏损你了不起就亏一点点嘛
就像我刚刚那样子
说不定给你逮到5分K的破底翻
然后出去啊对不对
了不起就亏一点点嘛
就这样
那如果你心裡接受大顆度還在殺
短顆度這樣子還沒有到很穩定
但是短顆度又有東西
兩邊在打架對不對
你就接受它是其中一邊的那個交易計畫
好那我選一個滑膝肝膀
我知道勝率偏低
那你還要想要做
我們就接受啊
就這樣子好不好
所以我现在是密切在观察什么
这个边界
如果这个边界在1分K里面已经快要出现
啊有啦
来这就是我讲的1分K的边界
但是这个1分K
你等这个1K收定
现在9点58
大概在30秒
这一分钟就要收
你等他收
隔壁这边这里
才是你比较适合的下单点
你下单在这边你的防守我看一下
可以呢
你也可以直接锁到外面去
你不用锁这个
你直接吃这边锁到外面去
这已经是最极限的吃法了
大概300美金的风险
我锁住了我不能吃
这样
这个就是我们讲的
这里打破应该要整个跌下去
应该整个下去
却没有下去
然后被某个神秘力量拉回来
你心里要到底哦
这只是1分K的事情
所以他可能还会在这边
这里来回震荡一段时间
BTC有真的吗?比特币有
BTC
21.40看到
BTC,比特币的日线这里很漂亮
对吧
各位这个边界就这里啊,6万5这里很漂亮啊
你要讲的是什么 21.40 21.40在哪里这个有IU等一下如果你在五分K这边没有任何的这里没有任何的标准图可以下单啊
这了不起就只是这样子
不要啦
这个没有标准图哦
这怎么吃都不对哦
这里不对哦
如果你要吃多单
你好歹也在
也在这样子
下沙
破以后的隔壁吃
对吧
现在这个单子这里有压力
这里有支撑不好做
好不好
10点钟了
恭喜刚刚有吃到原油
原油波动最近真的有够快
又快又大
所以就因为这样子
所以它那个利润来的速度
其实坦白讲蛮快的
但是我锁住我不下单
各位
又一次了
对吧
OK
这些全部都是在大家眼前
各位看到我这边的行情
大概会晚个
晚个十几二十秒
但是对我来讲这就是几时盘
就是现在的样子
对啊
好不好
那这个概念
可以摆在1分K
摆在5分K
摆在日线周线
其实都通用
都通用
然后我来看一下
刚刚上面好像有问到台积电是不是
我每次进场刻度都用1K的话
没有哦你看我刚刚来
我们看我刚刚的案例
我虽然在1K进场
但是我的脑袋里早就有这边是大刻度
我用原油的样子
原油原油
我的脑袋里
我当时吃1K
我可能在这附近吃的
但是我早就有5K的事情
所以我吃在区间的下缘
我摆明就是做到区间上缘
把它出掉
所以我当时的单子
这边还有
我就是这么做的
区间的下缘
做到区间上缘把它出掉
这样
这样OK
就是这个想法而已
来 刚刚比特币我刚刚在讲的
现在连比特币都变成我养的有没有你等他破了以以後大家都停損了哇這邊摸多單的人停損了以後你再來找機會吃不是很好嗎
幹嘛跟人家急著在第一隻腳就要做多單呢
不用吧
對吧
我們都講在前面哦
好不好
上周我同事买在198年的台积电
台积电好了
我们看一下台积电好了
来
我只能跟大家说
老鱼在说能不能在听
2000块那时候很多人发
好像还有网友说拿500万
压了买2000块的台积电
我好像看到那个文章
对不对
希望他
他熬得下去啦
这样子
因为跌到1800应该就很难熬
对啊这样子
我200万剩下
剩下一百八十万
一张赔二十万
还还好啦
对吧
买五百万也不过才亏
亏五十万而已
还好啦
那现在
现在我不知道
我没有打算在现在
刻意的去
讲出一个什么方向
我只知道现在是乱乱的
所以那不符合我喜欢的点
而且又这么高
放掉
你会发现我很挑
我很不喜欢
刚刚我好像有瞄到有人问什么
是万海吗还是什么
是有人问万海吗
万海的日线
嗯
是说风险不大啦
你可以守这边啦
这样子
但是这个日线我没有到很爱
它的周线丑丑的耶
对啊
这么多的这个出货的这个丑丑的耶
哎呀
我不会很爱
好不好
好了
2070周线是不是漂亮的互换
我们用个五分钟回答一下大家的股票的问题
好吗
這個嗎?2070
2070你要問的是什麼?
周縣是不是漂亮的呼喚?
周縣!
蛤?
没有互换啊
等一下等一下
来一张互换的图
你会在你的视野里面很清楚的看到这个东西
这个
我怎么比对都
我没有东西啊
如果他是这样子哦
整理
上去回来这里
可以老鱼这是不是清楚的互换
是
是是是这样
对吧
你这样可以理解吗
这才是漂亮的互换
但是像现在这里
如果你是往后看
老玉这里啊
本来的压力变成本来的支撑
太远了啦
这个已经是2022到23了耶
不要
好不好
那我眼前这样看
我只告诉
告诉我自己
我眼前看到的东西
当下
就是这个当下
我看到什么
我看到周线还在往下
这样子
所以除非这一周
打一个比较明确一点的脚
打个尖尖的下影线收进来
我隔壁的这一周
下一周我才会开始
匡列我的打击区
所以这个打脚的概念
大概要像这样子
大概像这样
假设有这个
隔壁你再来做
我觉得都不迟
这样子
好不好
拜托
等一下
現在有點硬喔 好不好
我旁邊看到什麼我就看什麼
有同學問EUR USD
歐元喔 好啊
然後呢1.158
你要問的是問應該是五分可以吧
我猜
是哪里
我们的价格不太一样
因为欧元这个不同交易所
每个交易所给你的价格都不一样
所以我很难告诉你
你说日K
1.158
我没有办法
我说我没有办法
日K现在
我看不出东西来
我只能告诉你现在这样
因为每个人的平台看到的欧元都不一样而且差距有可能会很大哦所以我不敢跟你说到底是哪一个这样刘希你说老鱼怎么样
赶快讲啊
快点我看得到你
反正我现在旁边看到什么
我就先讲
这个让我先跳过好不好
有同學說DEA
DEA是什麼?
DEA
DEA倒是可以喔
可以有這個周線打這種
你心裡就要有個底了
就是這個邊界理論上該下去
可以也可以
然後還有什麼
SMCI好
我就直接在這邊看
你要問我什麼呢
SMCI
SMCI在哪裡
寫寫的往上嗎
日線喔
沒有喔
這日線就是長這樣子
它沒有到很美
我沒有很美
它就是
就是在一個很大的區間裡面就是這樣子
30塊到33塊上下10%
這樣子
然后还有什么
M、Marvel
你要看什么
这个是现在的盘的吧对不对
我现在懒得去我IP那边切
直接这样切比较快
TS活6个月很好了啦
很好了
Marvel这里你要问我这里吗
你是要做空是不是
还是你是多单要出
如果是多單你可以出一點點留一些賭賭看
因為目前一週這樣第二週現在是週二嘛
現在正遇到一些抵抗
如果你熬過這個出去應該就海闊天空了
不是這個哦
那我就先看別的好不好
同學看什麼東西
KMX IONQ KMX
這個嗎?
CARMAX我先解起來好了IB看比較清楚好像是我其實應該用
KMX
我都會習慣看到圖就先退一步
可以啊周線我就不錯啊
市場有支撐
但是注意
微微尷尬的點是
這邊有支撐他很快速會遇到壓力
所以如果從這個角度來看
日線這樣看就沒有很愛
其實
對啊
沒有很愛
IONQ
這是什麼呢?
這個也不錯耶
這個的長線
可以喔
同學還蠻會選的啊
只是你心裡要有底
包含像日線
他這些剛上來回來
他還是會在這邊震盪的
這個機率蠻高
而且你看這邊蠻多上影線在這裡
上面這裡
所以你心中就有個底拉
這樣子
我不是會很吃太大的部位
我会拉如果你要做到周线
我就拉长长的周线
然后抓一个这个宽宽的这个
这样子的角度
慢慢吃慢慢吃这样子
那设一个总风控这样子
好吧
哎呦我之前有call in
只是我最近忘记用call in这件事情
然后呢
MRV3月5号被点掉
好
我这样看得懂了
所以你3月5号被点掉
然后这个
倒霉不知道股票是可以守更远一点
我不确定你用哪一个
等级的防守
其实股票我觉得可以
因为我的习惯都是用很大刻度
甚至我到现在我很多时候
我是有些单子我根本就不停损
反正我就钱丢着
因为那些钱都是多出来的钱
所以本质上就会
反正都是多出来的你就会觉得反正就丢着吧就这样子对好不好如果我是你其实我事先看过这个周线的话我心中会有个底周线在这
周线在这
整区的边界
其实如果你是守到周线的边界
坦白讲比较合理
这样子
因为他周线的长相是这样子
对啊
所以我比较习惯
我不会只守刚刚好
那如果我是刚被点掉
注意哦
这边提醒一下
如果是今天刚被点到
我人正好在盘前
我会进到小颗度
例如说
你很衰的被这个点掉
被
被这个点掉
被这个
点掉了这样子
你可能点在这里
结果这时候你发现这个
我就会把我的部位建回来
这时候假设你原来的部位
我不知道多少钱
我建回来的部位
我就不用建到原来一样的部位
我可能先建一半
因为如果错了
就错一半就好
对吧
就错这个的一半
这样子就好
所以你可以在60K这边
去测试那个
像我刚刚一开始讲
那个AMD的那种一样
这样子
好吧
同学说小娜要来到60K边界
是吗
我们来看一下小娜
好了
看完小娜就准备下课了
其实今天的课也已经超时了
我原本预计讲到10点而已
又来一次你看小纳长这样子
这边对多头不利
所以市场真的很贱
他就是要先往上一段才会下来
那其实差不多
My top step不能留仓建议
我跟你说
没有什么建议不建议
因为有些人他做5K习惯
有些人做15K习惯
有些人做1K习惯
我给你一个通用的法则
准则好了
不是法则
越短
波动速度越快
但是好处是你可以说风险
坏处是
因为波动很快
杂讯很多
你可能会多赔个一两次
然后心理的压力
就是那个跳动的压力会很大
这是短线的缺点
那它的優點就是我剛剛講的風控
我今天做原油的短線是因為它風控真的太大
我只好縮到1K
不然我也很喜歡在5K跟15K做
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕